so we're about to board an armored
vehicle right here that will uh drive us
across the firing range and according to
the drill scenario uh
the terrorists have captured a village
and now our mission is going to be to uh
get there as quick as possible and
well neutralize them
we've been given exclusive access to an
elite motorized unit of the kyrgyz
military and this is a unique
opportunity to see them in action close
up it's pretty loud and cramped inside
this armored personal carrier this is a
vtr17 by the way and it's definitely not
designed for comfort now let me give you
a look uh from the outside of the cabin
so
as you can see
we're leading this charge
and there are several other armored
vehicles behind us uh that are following
our lead
this is the third and final day of a
military exercise called frontier 2021
which is organized by russia and three
of its central asian allies kyrgyzstan
tajikistan and kazakhstan the war games
are held every year but this time
they're happening against the backdrop
of the us withdrawal from afghanistan
which has sent shockwaves through this
region
the world is alarmed by the situation in
and around afghanistan and some members
of our organization share borders with
afghanistan not long ago i visited the
afghan tajik border and i saw what was
happening there our main goal is to be
ready for any situation that could
develop that's why the main theme of our
drills is the fight against terrorism
we've not forgotten about the threats
near our country's borders
we're approaching
uh and
this is where the real election starts
the drills are held in several stages
tanks and artillery engage the enemy
first to prevent them from advancing
then two meet eight transport
helicopters drop special forces off
behind enemy lines to prevent the
militants from escaping and that's when
our unit of several dozen armored
vehicles comes in
well that was quick so the enemy has
been completely encircled and
neutralized and uh mission accomplished
now we need to get back to the vehicle
[Music]
after drills i'm going to play football
my favorite football player is cristiano
ronaldo of course
so the main goal of this rails of course
is to improve the level of cooperation
and interoperability between the nations
involved but in addition to this there
was a message that moscow and its allies
remain uh alert during this tumultuous
time that is following the disastrous
u.s withdrawal from afghanistan
casa de roshikov reports for rt from
kyrgyzstan
you